si certaines personnes ont des noms
particuliers comme de savoir bien jouer
au foot ou de présenter un prime sur les
chiens
un peu plus étrange Nicolas Fraisse est
dotée d'une faculté pour le mois
étonnante quotidiennement il sort de son
corps je suis à l'extérieur comme des
Américains la décorporation consiste
donc au pouvoir de sortir librement de
son propre corps et de se déplacer
tranquille ou ailleurs tu te fatigues
par exemple pour sécher les cours que le
courant ne m'intéressait pas je partais
je me retrouver chez mes parents et pour
moi c'était quelque chose de tout à fait
normal des scientifiques essaie
d'expliquer ce phénomène par une
projection de la conscience que c'était
souvent par une opération médicale de
mort imminente de nombreuses personnes
ayant frôlé la mort par la suite une
expérience extraordinaire qui s'est
produite au moment où elle était dans un
coma profond ou même en état de mort
clinique il faut voir ce qui lui cette
expérience hors du commun passe un
moment à peine croyable hors de leur
corps
on pense qu'à une dizaine de pourcents
de personnes qui peuvent vivre ce
phénomène au moins une ou deux fois dans
leur vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
expérience de mort imminente rapidement
qu'est-ce que c'est
des personnes qui ont frôlé la mort
suite à un accident un arrêt cardiaque
et ont rapporté par la suite a réussi un
peu
qui sort de l'ordinaire
une décoration avec sentiment de
bien-être
sont attirés par un tunnel avec
amour et il rencontre parfois des proche
décédé qui leur dise que c'est pas leur
et il faut que tu retournes fantôme du
château à l'heure vous vous avez une
expérience vous avez quoi un accident
parce que j'avais du mal à respirer
ça fera le tour de moi j'ai dit si je
m'allonge je meurs et donc du coup ça a
calmé un petit peu tout le tout le monde
dans la salle d'opération effectivement
je me suis allongé j'ai pas le souvenir
d'avoir posé la tête sur sur la table je
me suis retrouvée immédiatement éjecté
de mon corps et de nouveau assis sur
cette table d'opération le seul souci
c'est que tout était blanc autour de moi
je voyais que je me rappelle même avoir
fait ça devant moi et je voyais pas mes
mains je voyais je voyais plus rien tu
te tais blanc mais je suis en fait
j'avais deux bras et que j'étais assise
encore sur cette table d'opération dans
l'hôpital fin voilà sortie de votre
corps Ouais ouais je me suis vraiment
redresser en fait j'étais en train de
manger si vous voulez pour pour me faire
opérer et je me suis de nouveau retrouvé
assis et libéré de de toutes les
couleurs que j'avais pu avoir jusqu'à
est-ce que vous êtes au réveil après
l'opération vous avez fait un arrêt
cardiaque où vous étiez en état de mort
de mort de mort c'est mort
alors justement à plusieurs
quelque chose de témoignages que j'ai
pris mes affaires j'ai retrouvé une
infirmière en fait qui qui travaillait
sur le
sur le bloc en fait où j'étais et elle
me dit tu sais il y a un truc un peu
étrange et qu'il y a pas de d'adrénaline
en fait sur ton cas et donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas eu de arrêt cardiaque donc
c'est pas un souci c'est que de votre
plein gré
alors ça c'est encore différent on a
toujours l'impression c'est qu'on
revient de son plein gré en fait c'est
pas un choix ni le départ ni le retour
là je m'ennuie je m'ennuie je peux
déplace ailleurs si on peut on peut ça
recherche mais est-ce qu'on fait le
cobaye pour sortir de soi-même
et puis on se concentre et puis on nous
demande d'aller voir ce qui se passe
dans une autre pièce
[Rires]
pas jusqu'à même vous dire que je suis
passé à travers un mur j'ai vu ce qu'il
y avait le côté alors je vous laisse
imaginer seulement ramener un souvenir
comme ça mais pour moi je peux je peux
pas vous dire autre chose vous me diriez
si vous continuez à nous dire ça on va
vous en faire mais je crois que je serai
prêt à être enfermé je continuerai à la
maison
Ouais
est-ce que ça c'est sûr l'expérience je
vais je vais vous raconter l'expérience
tout à fait mais effectivement un moment
donné ou un autre dans cette expérience
j'ai souhaité voir mes enfants et donc
il médiatement je me suis retrouvé à la
maison voir mes enfants est-ce qu'il
peut être assez rigolo aussi c'est quand
je suis arrivé devant la maison j'ai
bien vu devant la maison tout ce qu'il y
avait dehors je voyais que les molécules
c'est-à-dire j'explique dans mon
témoignage avait des petits pieds de
tomates en fait qui devait pas être plus
haut que ça et je les voyais pas comme
je peux les voir aujourd'hui je voyais
toutes les molécules j'avais la
compréhension de ses pieds de tomates
j'ai même passer la main à l'intérieur
et j'étais ses pieds dans la matière
c'est ça comme Lucy le film c'est un peu
ça vraiment
je suis rentré à la maison
aujourd'hui
à vous voir comme vous êtes et il y a
quelque chose de supplémentaires c'est
que tout ce que vous avez là en ce
moment dans la tête et je l'ai aussi et
j'avais les souffrances de mes enfants
les peurs les angoisses tout ça ça m'a
pardonné en fait et on prend ça en fait
comme un